cosa ci dici di questo menù molto bello
molto ricco di casa cosa dice lui niente
amore ecco volevo salutarti velocemente
il dirti che ti amo tanto
o ti do vinho un po sarà di ritorno a
casa molto presto prima ora devo tornare
al lavoro
sappi che ti amo e ethan armi ma anche
molto attivando maestà ci siamo tanto
parlare della mobilità quindi e lorenzo
che è il tutto ho visto in questi titoli
quello che posso dirti che se troverai
questo
n lontano quindi piccola cosa è la
storia lui deve andare a far vicine alla
casa che andrà a visitare 10 lei chiama
quindi veramente fatto così non pensavo
ragazzi quest'anno inizio e che merita
questa ragazza quindi qua dovrebbe
esserci la tipa che ha mandato il mi ami
ha segnato il bello capito secondo me
risponderà sicuramente qualcuno cioè
questo la pizza ha commentato livio ma
con cenni marco a rastrellare un genio
viene poi loro le pistole una carabina
ecco adesso buongiorno beh giustamente
una bella giornata come biasimare questo
giusto di comandare della rai aveva
accolto spesso è sparito è scappato nel
binario 9 e 3 4
la borsa michael cosa c'è dentro
inchiostri qualcosa da donna patente
cose che io non ho perso è influenza in
tracce del chip bertello sinistra dc mi
sa che non l'hanno di pianto molto alle
cifre bella ma che cos'è uno e uno è un
personaggio personaggi in casa natale
una patente osava mente per aprire anche
ad avere sentito le cose di ricordare il
nome mani e con il quadro ma ci sto
passiamo col primo nube si gioca tra
freccetta e nella mia testa
cos'altro grazie poi non ho questa una
domanda e volevo farvi siccome nella
demo nella demo c'è un bivio perché se
tu fai quasi subito qua c'è stava
scherzando si punta vogliamo scritto
sentirci acquisibile suoi
non c'è più quindi stava scherzando
adesso quindi come sai che la demo e
come succede per partire che succede
prima questa cosa non doveva più questa
cosa non mi doveva succedere anche
perché non so come risalire va bene
comunque ragazzi qua non ci sono mai
stato non so che cosa c'è e questa cosa
mi mette ansia perché non so che cosa ci
può essere capito però mica tuffare
network sicuro divertente ma aprire solo
il colpo per colpo l'ora l'amarezza di
giocare queste non sono stato io ha
scoraggiato giuro che schifo quindi
beretta ma anche scoreggia questo di
esko salve
adesso che abbiamo ragazzi se è vero che
ci sono anche i verbi male sarà la
scelta era fantina oddio 2100 adesso
alla cella
oddio rights action calcio quando esiste
una parete lorenzo la modesta come non
ci sono delle tenaglie tronchesi che lo
farà prima o poi qualche notabile
maroniti girare mango stato anche c'è un
buco nel muro qualcosa da dire che lei è
morta
non credo con questa che oggi la
maschera mia
per fortuna se vi va sono io sono
italiane stai bene tu non dovresti
essere qui greco ha contattato tu no non
sono stata io a qualcuno piace entrare
lui che ha visto
ma c'è qualcun altro che diavolo succede
qui sta arrivando papa dobbiamo andarci
ma dobbiamo andarcene adesso
noi ci ha portato nella tana del demonio
è questa cessata ma proprio questa una
porta sola giuseppe bellocco e
quest'altro tribune qui doveva paci
quale ricorda la stanza a scorretta è
vero poi c'era una porcata quella di
quel cavolo problema non ricordo nella
demo tra cui era caduta la creatura del
soffitto me lo ricordo famiglia gru è
quindi utile in questo momento è mia ma
cosa ma come è la porta a cena
lasciamoli qualcuno ci dirà che abbiamo
[Musica]
detto no scherzavo
ma non c'era nessuna prima cosa devo
scendere di nuovo tra l'altro non si
vede più niente
[Musica]
in quella maglia è bravo a fare questi
moti guarda me la cavo la catalogna ai
ghiacci highlander
basta
grazie
se riesco a sentirla pure io cazzo
dentro il mio corpo
lasciami stare non mi sono scusato tutto
questo però va bene no non mi schiero la
dea
devo andare io domani e non posso fare
queste cose
l'attacco non farò adesso mamma credo
che questo faccia ma questo
ma il segno meno giardini estende per
capirci ascom alla rete tutti sti mentre
buttafuori prevista a 100 certo l'hai
proprio lasciata a sta sfidando il tempo
non volevo dare un'occhiata a mano o
jordan questa mia figlia pizza per due
quindi justin chi sei e che cazzo
succede
comunque io non capisco quanto sono
danneggiato se mi conviene usare il kit
cos'ha detto
sicuramente la tipa non c'è più la
faccia più la tipo di lasciare vinto nel
quadro era brutta affanculo m'aspettavo
giuro è tranquilla prima fissato in modo
di farmi male agli associati ha fatto
trasparire
basta vicino a quello
o no
e vabbè non è che si farà con per
creazioni c'è gioco alla mano è una mano
ma che cattura e non sono mora ai fatti
con spirito giusto si è poi giocare è
una cosa che non è finito sotto qualcosa
quello sì prossima shm gam e non ci sta
credendo questa cattiva ad ora quindi
non sono morto
leggo era pilotato per me questo non gli
fa male c'è non è aperto lo sta tenendo
no alla sua voglia desidera del durello
l'area nissi ma io mica vado sotto fare
qua scena sono tributi la foto con fibre
la popolazione si sarebbe bello per le
mani in questo momento non cosa dica io
aspetto
il nuovo verbale
la ragazza
e lei come uscita
ahia
hyatt e non la pregio non ci penso
i miliari che non potranno una tombola
dai quartieri
secondo te sai lavorativo senza
abbraccio è un vecchio ente c'è anche un
motivo
anche lei nemmeno visto
ma sicuro intanto questa si alza un pò
quindi poi fa mica lo scenario è uguale
al mio dentista tra l'altro vero ti
giuro non ho molto più gravi
o c'è chi l'ha fatto con lo scotch e le
vuole un braccio nuovo no veramente
maione cozze quelle stesse n chiarito
milioni e allora della pappa e voi siete
dove mia mangia è buono non distingue
dalla merda non ce l'hanno con le
braccia e le mele nazione piccola come
non per averlo fatto adesso il ragazzo
non deve mangiare la sua cella se mi dai
il braccio di mare speciali non ne ho
idea non lo voglio
mangia mangia gli schifosi maiali è
spuntata una vecchia centrica manager e
anche prima se ti do la pista ma io
quindi non ho capi giornata il nonno
punti si è rigenerato il braccio ma
scusami se solo a fare lo si va dai
ragazzi io direi che possiamo chiudere
questa prima misurini residenti vola
ringrazio marco e c è un certo trambusto
ai padri quel buffet dove mangiare cazzo
mangia ma viene delle mani dal caen né
ai troppi però mi sia piaciuto passate
anche al khaliq di ciccio e di marco che
rilascia una descrizione comunque sia
storia costume non sia piaciuto
continuano al prossimo consiglio ragazzi
di regione momento invece anche vari
social come nei video tenere il tizio
non c'era già un antico ricordo dei
ragazzi